[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone, and
welcome to the 2017 TensorFlow
developer summit, and I'm
delighted to see all of you
here today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: Today we are excited
to announce TensorFlow 1.0.
TensorFlow's
philosophy has always
been to give you the power
to do whatever you want,
but also make it easy, and
this makes it even easier.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 3: We really were hoping
to build a machine learning
platform, for everyone in the
world that was fast, flexible,
and production ready.
SPEAKER 4: The
point of TensorFlow
was to figure out
how can we give
this back to the
community, and be
able to use
TensorFlow to further,
whether it's the research
or their production needs?
SPEAKER 5: It's how
we express our ideas,
and it's the piece of
software our engineers
and scientists spend most of
their time interacting with.
SPEAKER 6: So TensorBoard
is a really exciting tool.
It's something that
will let you take
the confusing
world of TensorFlow
and start to dive into it.
SPEAKER 7: It's just
a really amazing time
to be an AI researcher.
SPEAKER 8: One of the projects
that we've been working on
is using deep learning
for retinal imaging.
SPEAKER 9: Can we use deep
learning and reinforcement
learning to generate
compelling media?
SPEAKER 10: But this
is just the beginning.
The TensorFlow community
is truly global.
SPEAKER 11: We want to see all
the amazing things that you
guys can do with TensorFlow.
Thank you very much.